en este apartamento A las afueras de
Beijing Angry y su esposo tan joayung
disfrutan jugando con su hijo de 2 años
Aunque ven poco probable tener un
segundo hijo
si tenemos en cuenta que nuestros padres
están envejeciendo Y al menos uno de
nosotros tendría que hacer el sacrificio
y quedarse en casa para cuidar al bebé
así que esperaremos y veremos
una decisión cada vez más común en China
que ve como su explosión demográfica de
antaño se ralentiza rápidamente mientras
el mundo alcanza los 8.000 millones de
habitantes los motivos son varios desde
el elevado coste del cuidado de los
niños pequeños en Jardines o con
cuidadores y la falta de ayuda de los
abuelos que muchas veces viven lejos y
son mayores hasta que como tan de 39
años muchos chinos forman sus familias
cada vez más tarde
muchos de nosotros nos casamos muy tarde
y Es difícil tener un bebé a esa edad
creo que casarse tarde tendrá un impacto
en los nacimientos
una realidad muy distinta a la de la
década de los 80 cuando el gobierno
impuso una ley de hijo único para
mantener las cifras bajo control razón
por la que tanto como Tank son
justamente eso hijos únicos como Venga
pues no creo que deba tener más hijos
porque la taza de natalidad esté bajando
estamos felices con un solo hijo los
jóvenes por su parte prefieren centrar
sus vidas en otras cosas antes que tener
un bebé por las mismas razones que en
occidente alto coste de vida y otros
intereses según Fuentes oficiales China
tiene una tasa de fertilidad del
1,16%. lejos del 2,1% necesario para una
renovación poblacional saludable se
espera que la población empiece a
reducirse a partir del año que viene
todo un reto para el gigante asiático
que a pesar de ser un país en desarrollo
verá envejecer rápidamente a su
población y disminuir su fuerza de
trabajo en los próximos años